sanitation is the key to permanent rat
control
for it strikes at the rats basic
requirements of food and harborage
to reinforce the effects of sanitation
rats must be cut off from entry into
buildings through any actual or
potential
openings an exposed wooden edge on a
door affords the rat a starting place
for knowing and eventual entry
starting with a 1 8 inch crack
a rat can no on opening in a single
night
wooden window frames are penetrated with
the same ease
most foundation vents are open doors for
rats
service wires can be runways to
entrances otherwise beyond reach
rat proofing is the treatment of
buildings to prevent rat entry or exit
the knowing ability of rats is
remarkable
their cutting tools are their long sharp
incisors
in one series of experiments rats in
search of food cut through a variety of
materials
1 8 inch compressed fiber hardboard with
a quarter inch gnawing edge was
penetrated in two nights
quarter inch plywood with no knowing
edge
four nights
3 8 inch plasterboard with no gnawing
edge
five nights
3 8 inch marine sheathing no gnawing
edge
seven ninths
two inch foam glass no knowing edge
13 knights
24 so aluminum alloy almost a tenth of
an inch thick
knowing edge one quarter inch
11 knights
asbestos flex board
3 16 inch thick with an 11 16 inch hole
took 51 nights
with the simulated channel of 61 st
aluminum alloy one fiftieth of an inch
thick with a quarter inch knowing edge
it took 170 nights to penetrate one
thickness
some materials however such as
galvanized sheet iron are almost
completely rat resistant
galvanized sheet iron and galvanized
hardware cloth are the basic materials
used in typical rat proofing operations
large centralized workshops should be
equipped with a metal splitter
a specially designed metal bound work
table
templates developed for use in
repetitive shop operations
and a complete set of sheet metal hand
tools
a metal bending break is also essential
employees should be skilled sheet metal
workers since each item fabricated must
be custom made
careful attention to field
specifications is necessary or the
completed work will be useless and will
have to be scrapped
central workshops speed rat proofing
operations by providing adequate
workspace for the required equipment
much of which is large and cumbersome
close attention should be given to the
arrangement of the equipment so as to
save time in moving materials from one
to the other
a complete array of sheet metal
equipment expedites fabrication provides
consistent quality
and gives the finished materials a
uniform craftsman-like appearance
which is pleasing to the user
and to the public
fabrication instructions must be based
upon efficient design
they must specify proper materials and
methods of assembly so as to assure
adequate protection against wrath
knowing over a maximum life span
thus galvanized hardware cloth could be
used without a metal frame
but experience has shown that its useful
life is greatly prolonged by placing it
in a sturdy metal frame
large items can be fabricated easily in
the shop
thus field personnel are freed to devote
their time to installation work
and to fabricating small items
in order to expedite installation of rat
proofing materials on buildings a mobile
workshop can be designed to permit
simple on-the-job fabrication
and to carry equipment necessary for
installation
it should provide work tables
a metal bending brake
and hand tools for metal work woodwork
and masonry
also it must have storage space for
standard rat proofing materials such as
galvanized sheet metal galvanized
hardware cloth cement
bricks and for various sizes of lumber
the materials used and the method of rat
proofing depend on the job to be done
this wooden door was cut through because
its loose fit gave the rat annoying edge
it can be rat proofed with a standard
metal cuff and channel
the threshold should be of metal
or at least should be covered with sheet
metal
clearances around the door should be 3 8
inch or less
treatment of the door the threshold and
the jams with sheet metal
prevents rat entry by knowing
naturally if the door is left open it
fails to keep out the rats
more rats enter buildings through open
doors than by any other means
if a door must be kept open for
ventilation or other purposes
the entrance should be protected by a
rat proof screen door equipped with
self-closing hinges
the lower edge of the screen door should
be cuffed and channeled
the rats cannot enter any opening if the
width or height of the opening is less
than one half inch
hardware cloth with a half inch mesh
will keep rats out
a quarter inch mesh will keep mice out
also
this window should be repaired
a rat proofing screen of a quarter or
half inch mesh hardware cloth in a sheet
metal frame
should be installed in front of the
window
foundation vents should be protected by
hardware cloth of a quarter or half inch
mesh
holes left by the installation of
service pipes should be filled
immediately with a good grade of cement
mortar
such rat proofing measures while of the
utmost importance
are relatively simple and obvious
others are more difficult and extensive
for instance this seller is rat infested
how did rats get in
they burrowed under the foundation wall
and entered through the earthen floor of
the cellar
rat proofing of sellers can be
accomplished in one of two ways
an l-shaped curtain wall of concrete can
be built adjoining the foundation wall
to a depth of 24 inches below the
surface of the ground
the lip of the curtain wall should be at
least 12 inches wide and four inches
thick
curtain walls are effective because of
the habits of rats
occasionally rats seeking an entry may
burrow 8 to 12 feet deep beside a
foundation wall
usually they will not give up unless
they meet a horizontal obstruction which
they take to be a floor
rats apparently refuse to burrow away
from their objective
l-shaped curtain walls of these
dimensions have thus far baffled rats
another way of rat proofing the cellar
is by installing a concrete floor
closely joined to the foundation wall
this is the method of choice because it
excludes rats and at the same time adds
value to the building
rats excluded from a building by sealing
off their usual routes will seek other
ways of access
thus it is necessary to make it
impossible for rats to enter less
accessible points
for example
either this tree should come down
or the window should be rat proof
these eaves are potential points of
entry
they are accessible from the roof and
from the wires along the side of the
house
covering the eaves with hardware cloth
protects the building from rats and also
from squirrels and birds
ventilation the purpose of the open
eaves
remains effective
roofs which rats are able to reach
need special attention
on this roof
rats are harboring at the junction of
the parapet wall and the roof
and are entering the building through
the soil vent pipe
hardware cloth protects the soil vent
from rat entry
the next step should be to eliminate the
harborage at the parapet wall
in any building
every probable point of rat entry must
be located
and then rat proofed
there are many types of buildings that
need rat proofing
each has problems peculiar to its
geographical location
the type of construction
and proximity to other buildings
but it is not only the exteriors of
buildings that have to be treated
many establishments are so constructed
that they furnish an unnecessary amount
of interior structural harborage
the double partition wall is the most
common example of structural harborage
within this double wall for instance
there is a norway rat nest
another double wall provides a perfect
runway for roof rafts
after rat proofing is completed
rats usually are found to be still in
the building
where a building contains sources of
food and water plus adequate harborage
the rat population inside the building
will continue to thrive until further
rat control measures are taken
the remaining rats must be killed
special rat killing techniques have been
devised to speed rat eradication
in rat proof buildings
these special techniques should be used
immediately after rat proofing
in urban areas rat proofing problems
usually involve adjoining buildings
where buildings have exterior walls
almost adjoining
rats may harbor between the walls
feeding in the adjacent premises
or where the buildings have a common
wall the rats may harbor in one building
and feed in the next
this fact has an important bearing on
rat proofing of urban property
here is a half of a city block with a
frontage of 200 feet
and a depth of 75 feet
this half block is divided into eight
premises of equal size
each has a frontage of 25 feet
and a depth of 75 feet
if each premise is to be rat proof
separately
work will have to be done on a total of
1075 linear feet
such rat proofing is expensive
but is it necessary to rat proof each
premise separately
study of rat habits indicates that rats
live in a limited home range
rarely do they cross a street
therefore for economy in rat proofing
the entire half block must be considered
not as individual premises
but as one unit
proofing the perimeter of the whole
group of adjoining premises
rat proofs the entire half block
and reduces the area to be treated to
about half
rat proofing on a block basis is both
the most efficient and most economical
procedures
and complies with the island theory of
rat control
the island theory assumes that each
block forms an island of rat life
after the block has been rat proofed the
rats within each premise are eradicated
after a block has been rat proofed and
rat freed it has to be maintained
damage to rat proof installations can
occur through accident
or carelessness
such damage may result in re-infestation
the window must be rat proofed again
and the building freed of rats
the most efficient the most economical
and the most lasting rat proofing
results from proper design and
construction of rat proof buildings
rat proof materials are used at all wrap
accessible points
material having a maximum opening of one
half inch in the least dimension
is used at all potential points of entry
that can be reached by rats
expanded metal as installed here
is far superior to hardware cloth
both in strength and permanence
rat proof construction eliminates most
of the interior harborage found in usual
construction
there are solid basement floors
and no double floors
or ceilings
no opening is left around service pipes
where they pass through walls
there are no double walls
there are no enclosed spaces in
stairwells nor boxed in spaces in or
under shelving
these are but a few of the features
recommended by revised building codes
aimed at the rat proof construction of
buildings
buildings so constructed can be kept rat
free with a minimum of labor and expense
when we learn to practice continuous
anti-rat sanitation
when all our buildings have been rat
proofed by techniques such as these
followed by thorough rat eradication
then man will have gone far toward
ridding himself of his unwanted and
deadly companions
the wrath
you